Stop it. I don't want to do this.
Don't ever fucking tell me that I don't do that.
I don't know. I'm sorry.
Thank you.
I'm the one that suggested it.
No more, TVG.
No, seriously. I'm the one that suggested it.
No more. No more.
Have you seen my eyes?
Huh?
That's not my problem.
It's not your problem.
That's why I'm telling you.
Stop it.
You're the one with the anger issue.
No, seriously.
Ricky, please.
I don't want to discuss this.
Okay?
Exactly.
That's exactly the fucking issue.
And not only do you not want to discuss it,
you don't even bother to look at all the work that I do.
Ricky, I don't...
I think that that's unfair.
No, it's not.
Okay, this is unfair.
Talk to mom.
Okay.
No, Ricky, I don't...
I don't want to...
Exactly.
That's exactly the kind of attitude.
And then three weeks later, you come to...
I'm sorry, man.
I'm not supposed to do this.
Huh?
I have a lot of things to do.
I have a lot of responsibilities.
I don't want to get...
No, this is bullshit.
Okay, for you it's bullshit.
It is bullshit.
So you're like, oh, I want you to do the accounting.
I'm not gonna...
You're not gonna understand this.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah.
As if...
As if I haven't been doing...
You know what?
Huh?
Stop and take it back.
Because I don't want to continue this discussion.
No, this is fucking bullshit.
No, no, no.
I can't fucking believe that you would...
I can't even fucking believe that you would say it like that.
I...
It's fucking unbelievable.
You know, we ended up...
I knew that we started talking...
And you ended up talking...
Talking bullshit.
And that's what I do want.
Yeah, you know why?
And I go to the...
Tell me exactly why I'm mad.
Tell me.
Tell me why I'm mad.
Because you think that I don't mind...
That I don't mind what you are doing.
I...
Of course, I do.
No, you don't.
Okay, but stop it.
No.
Okay.
Seriously.
What is the point?
Okay, I don't mind.
That's what I want me to tell you.
Don't mind.
Go to your business.
Do it in the way that you want.
Period.
But I cannot risk my health.
You're risking your own health.
Yes.
I am risking my own health...
With this nonsense.
It's not nonsense.
You know why?
You don't even glance...
At the spreadsheets that I make.
Vicky.
And then you come and preach...
Vicky, you are...
Okay.
You are...
Like, look how much...
Just...
And I don't understand...
Exactly.
You know why?
Because you don't even take the time to bother to look at the lines.
I, I, you said, Ricky, I am not excusing you.
Well, you act like one.
You act like one a lot.
But I know finance.
I know accounting.
Well, then, well, then, why don't you understand what I'm fucking doing?
My mom does.
My mom understands completely.
You are, you are connecting.
You are connecting this.
And, uh, that's fine.
I mean, I don't, don't, don't say, I don't say, uh, I don't say it's wrong.
I don't say, do it.
What is the point?
Do it.
The point is that you're coming and telling me.
No, I am telling you.
To do things that, that I'm, I'm actually doing and that I have been doing.
And that I was the one that tried to do it.
I'm the one that tried to set up the family financials.
And then, and then you don't give a fuck.
You don't, you don't even glance.
And then you come and tell me and preach about, oh, you should do this.
You should do that.
As if I haven't been doing exactly that.
And I've been trying to get you to do it.
You are.
Like, what the fuck are you talking about?
Yes.
What the fuck?
I'm talking about.
You are full of hatred.
Full of bad.
That's what I am talking about.
Are you serious?
Yes.
Totally serious.
No.
I mean, this is completely justified.
I, I, I, I, you are.
That's what, why, why am you taking me with this?
Because I don't speak.
Because you would go say that is because I have my reason.
And the reason is because.
Because you don't, you don't look.
You don't actually take the time or care or effort to look.
That's not an excuse.
It's not an excuse.
It is literally not an excuse.
Okay.
You have your way of thinking.
It's not a mind.
It's not a, it's not a quote unquote mind way of thinking.
In Demis, me and Taiki, we literally sat for two hours.
Trying to get you to do some basic bullshit.
Fucking second grade math.
That doesn't matter.
You know why?
No matter what, I'm not going to talk to you if you continue bitching me and telling me that.
Okay?
I'm not going to.
At least, like, like, make, like, you don't even make the effort to run the spreadsheet through an AI summary.
Like, you don't even have that little bit of respect just to, like, to at least fake or, like, even lift a single finger to actually, like, look at what I'm doing.
Do it.
No, you do it.
That's your job.
It's not my job.
Yes, it is.
Okay.
That's why you're saying that it's my job.
What?
I'm telling you.
I'm not going to do this.
It's not even a job.
I'm doing an actual job.
Do it.
I am already doing it.
So why is it so so angry?
Because you don't care! You don't look, you don't even pay a single finger, you don't even do the bare bare minimum, like even below the bare minimum.
And then you come and tell me about "oh you should do this"
I'm telling you that your money paid for QuickBooks 100% and you now...
No, and then I was like "oh well I didn't know about that because it's connected to my mom's personal account"
And then you started preaching about fucking "oh I should do this"
I am trying to help you!
No you're not! No you're fucking not because if you actually were, you know why?
It took you like how many arguments did it take for me to convince you to just make that one call to ask around for the Yuzu location?
Like if you actually wanted to help out, you would actually listen and do that.
Why should you do it? That's the word!
Because I don't know! That's the value that you can... I don't know!
You keep asking Noah how can you help and then we tell you exactly the ways that you can help and then you don't do it!
Ricky, Ricky, regarding the location...
No, no that's just an example, one example out of many.
Okay, regarding the accounting and regarding this accounting...
Again, these are just examples...
Dude, look, there's nothing... there's nothing that will change my position, Ricky!
Exactly! That's exactly the fucking point!
There's nothing, there's nothing that is... exactly that's the fucking issue!
If you continue...
You have no open mind!
If you continue discussing, you think that I am going to change, forget it!
I prefer to grasp, use to serve and close me!
So how is that not hatred? Oh, and then you call me "Oh, I'm a hatred!"
That's what you are acting to! That's what you are producing!
No, that's what you're...
You think that I am bitching me, that I am not doing this...
Okay, I tried to do what I could!
If you don't... if you want to know me to do more...
Even Taiki told you the same thing!
I cannot, no, I don't bring Taiki!
I'm sorry, I cannot do anymore!
Put video! Put it in that way!
That's bullshit!
Bullshit! Bullshit for you!
But not in the reality!
Bullshit for everybody else except for your little fucking fantasy!
Yeah, okay!
My, my fantasy!
Let me eat my fantasy!
I don't mind!
I know you don't mind!
But it affects everybody else!
I mean what...
It affects everybody else!
You are the emperor that is going to ruin my life!
What do you think?
Oh, okay!
Do you want me to stay...
To start telling you that you are...
What do you say?
To me?
I want you...
No, no, I'm not going to go to your level, Ricky!
Period!
My level?
Yes!
You think that I am a Christian!
of shit that you can
you think that I
deserve to be bitch
or fucking because that's
your way
of thinking
you are provoking me
for me to
start doing the same that you are doing to me
right because yes
if you have made a mistake I never
have told you hey this is a
F
word blah blah blah
I haven't changed my position
like I've been
me, Taiki, mom we've been telling
you the same thing over and over
and then you ask
that's exactly the issue dad
you're never going to change
that's exactly
what is it
I'm not going to change my position
Thank you.
Please don't forget the clothes.
I have my change of clothes, partly in my white backpack.
I have my change of clothes.
Where are you?
Middow Town?
Middow Town is already gone.
It's fine.
We can go.
I have my change of clothes.
I'll see him here again today.
But the next day I'll need it.
Ah, so...
Hi, I do...
Gabby but he almost won't be here today.
Ah, so?
Thank you old chIST
What's the weather?
みんなにいる?
ミッドタウンでいい?
モロポンゲンでいい?
みきどこに?
全然どこでもいいよ
みきさんの中に何があったかな
いろんなものがあるね
ああ
えーと
でも
みきさんとルースと両方が好きなものなんてないかもしれない
私はね
ちょっと
後でもう一回
会いますけど
ロポして
もう一回会います
ああそうだね
でも何回一緒に食べる?ご飯
私は大丈夫
え?どうして?
なんでかと言うと
急にね
仕事が
イメージをもっと深くなってたかな
ああ
今日は
何しよう
こんなにお天気よくなっちゃってごめんね
うん
やだなぁ
え?ほんと台風どうしたんだろう
でも
台風で大変だったところもあるのよね
鳥栃県とか
こんな風にもあったのかしら
いやでも昨日雨降ってたよね
やっぱり
うん
え?
そう
天田部長
牛は知ってる?
あれ?
大変な雨が降りましたね
そう
うちのも全然降らなかったね
雨
え?そう
うん
全然
だから
雨が降らなかったのに
悪いことしたのかなと思って
今日やめたなんて言ったら
こんなにいいお天気ね
うん
だからよかったら
明日でも明後日でも行ってもいいけど
パパも一緒でもいいけど
うん
明日もしね
群馬に行くなら
明日
明日何?
なんて言った
えっと
群馬県
群馬県?
うん
あの
え?もし行きたかったら
じゃあ、メンメン…えっと…何だったっけ?
えっと、美術館、パラ美術館。
あっ、あ、私、夢とくんでも忘れちゃったじゃない? 今日出しといたのに…
あはっ。
あ、そうい…あぁ、ダメだなよ。
今日、もう、きゃすごく慌ててたのよ。 急にウィキさん、おりから言ってきて。
あ、そうか、そうか。
もう、あの、ウィキにも何か書かなきゃ、 悪いなと思って。
またちょっと書いたの、行った?
ああ、うん、ごめん、見てない。 もう、ちょっと、ちょっと…
えっと…
あ、そうか、80秒ですかね。 結局の生活から…
あー
大丈夫
えーっと
あれ見ればいいから
多分インターネットで何か書いてある
え、熊県にあるの
だからね、昨日カルリザまで行ったばかりじゃない
だからちょっと遠すぎると思って
カルリザまで行かないで
左に行かないで
右に行くの
2つになってるところで
あ、そっかそっか
カルリザより少し近いよね
少しは近いけどね
あの、山がないからね
うん
薄い峠通らなくて行った
そっか
うん、開いてるらしいけど
うん?
えっと
今ウェブサイト見ててさ
開いてらしい
開いてると思うけど
ちょっと
電話して
うん?
うん
ここってどこ?
ここは食べるか?
ルイシとお昼ご飯は一緒に食べるんだと思ってたのに
そうじゃなきゃ、運転してもらうだけじゃなんだか変だな
コーヒーはパパ?
メンメンのママにね
書いたら「やっぱり車いるよ」って
そうじゃなきゃいつもルイシが運転したんで悪いのよって
今日だってね、関係ないのに来てくださるなよって言ったのさっき電話で。
明日ね?
うん
今日仕事しないと
そうか
うん
ミント食べてるし
美味しいお蕎麦が好きだから
それ食べてから行けばいいのに
うん
お蕎麦屋さん
普通
お客様といろんな
ディナーの所にお蕎麦なんて食べないでしょ
うん
ね
うーん
ここは? ここ何?アザオジュバン? いやでは6本木の近くね、あそこにの室。
あ、そうか。
もうすぐ6本木をね、そうか。
お待ちしております。
よかった、今日は銀行の方、普通の窓口の人が、すごく親切な人で、前にすごい声を挟んでね、
それで言った、そのお金はどこから来たんですか?なんて聞くの失礼ですよ。
えぇ、何それ?
ミキサーはびっくりしてて、えぇ、何それ?
お金は、違うところから、そこに移したの、あそこだと、プレッシアだったら、アメリカから出せるのね、アメリカに行った時に。
だから、アメリカに行ってもお金がいるじゃない、だから、キャッシュで持ってくの大変だから、そっちに移してたのね、一生懸命。
うん。
で、いつかはきっと、そっちの方、余計使うように、アメリカの方が長くなるかなと思って。
うんうん。
一生懸命映したから、少しいっぱい映したもんだから、そのお金どこから来たんですか?なんて、ひどいじゃない。
あはは。
盗んできました。
本当?
あはは。
うん。
眠いんでしょ、リッキはいつも、あの。
えっと、夜の方がいろんなことやってて、それで昼間寝てることが多いから。
うん。
やりたいし、大丈夫。
あ、ここミートタウンね。
うん。
やりたいし、大丈夫。
あ、ここミートタウンね。
うん。
あーここミートタウンね。
お待ちしております。
どこで?
あの、あの、もう、もう、もう、もう、ルーシーって本当に行っちゃうの?
えっと、明日ね。もし明日、群馬に行くなら、えっと、今日ちょっとこういう仕事をしないと。
うん。
大変、明日ね。難しい。
うん。そしたら、この辺でいいよね。どこに行こうか。いろんなとこちょっと見て。
うん。
ここでいいか、それで帰り帰りはどうするんだっけ?
帰りは、私は、ここに行くの。
えっと、4時半くらいでいい?ここ。
ここ。
OK。
そしたら、寝るし、何もそれで食べないの。
うん。あ、あそこ行けばよかった。なんか、コーヒーでも、すごい。
焼き鳥。
コーヒーのお店、どこだ?
うん。え、どこでもいいけど。え、じゃあ、パパ、芳葉に来るって。
はい。ありがとう。
じゃあね。
あ、それじゃ、クスメのうちのそばに、その焼き鳥屋さんっていうのを行かなくと、それがどこでいいですか?
いや、パイピ屋さん。焼き鳥屋さんって言うからさ、だって。
はい、一回も行ったことないからさ。
あ、どこ。
これ、何か。
あ~。
でも、焼き鳥ってあれ、なんか、串焼きみたいなんじゃないの?
うんうんうん。
え、でも、月辞めじゃなかったよね、たぶん。
うんうん。
うん。
ね。
え、でも、さっき、あれ、4時半に来て、一緒にお茶するって言って、大丈夫?
nie
抗
absol
oh
Oh, hold on.
どこにあるんだろう
Flight
flight
Solo
表着
うん
本当?これケータリング用
ね
ここも出るデザートだねやっぱり
僕がね、学んでるものを買ってね
座って食べるの
本当だ
見てみる?いいよ
うん
ご視聴ありがとうございました
本当?
うん。うん。そうするよ。
うん。それでもいいよ。
うん。
切れるとき。
これない。
うん。
普通に上にかけてあるよね。
分かんない。
うん。
ラタスイがある。
えっと。
きしで。
何でも欲しくないですか
9…ican…
in
todos
100… 私は私にとってもらえます。
私は私にとってもらえます。
私は私をおめでとうございます。
Oh.
etty was enough.
Yeah, it was smooth.
enfermed and erected flesh injury.
It's not a problem.
Okay.
Yeah, I was just looking at the tomato tissue.
Thank you.
席取ってあげる
何か飲み物欲しい
持っててあげる
これも入ってたよ
うん
何飲む?
メメは?
メメかくらせる
メメかくらせる?
ハウスブレンドのスモールで
ハウスブレンドはホットレーズがよろしいですか?
はい
これだけはホットレーズ?
スモールでよろしいですか?
はい
ちょっとデザート
あれも楽しかった?
うん
3.926円
はい。
ありがとう。
大丈夫。
え、さて、持ってあげる。
これだけで、なんか、手なんかいらない?
大丈夫。
ありがとうございます。
はい。
めめめにティッシュ少し欲しい。これ温めてくれた。
あ、そう。
え、でもめめにかわいそう。
ありがとうございます。
あれ?
うん。
ありがとうございます。
美味しい
あ、それ何?カバト?
レモンって丸ごと食べるはずなの?
なんかピックルズみたいに
瓶につけてあるレモン
わかんない
でも昨日夜雨降ったよね多分
覚えてる感じ
でも映ること全然雨降ったね変だね
うん
美味しい美味しい
きっぱいもうじんおつそらく
submission
collect your programs
船は吞に Hit mems
うん、パスタって。
昨日ママと話したのじゃ
よかった
今朝電話入ってたけど
何もさ
寝てて出られなかった
あんまの中間は
あんまになかなか
ノーって言わない人は
だから
高子さんとかね
うん
あの子だったら
あれ
そうやってとか
うん
あと
どん
で後の方から帰ってきたんだ
みんな待って
どんどん
犬からみんな
うん
ああ
ああでも高子さんは
あれ
あの今
あのゆずのさ
ボトリングやってるところ
うん
そうか
いやからえっと
12月までなのね
その新しいなんか
かっこいいなのね
そうそうそうそう
それ高子さんと一緒にやってるから
そのせいだと思うけど
わかんない
うん
お豆腐ね?お豆腐買ってきててそのまま中で食べる?一回茹でる?
普通お味噌汁に入れる
昔はみんなの中でそのまま食べたらしいです。みんなの人って茹でちゃうからね。味が違うんだって誰かが言ってたから。めめもいつも茹でて食べるね。
お豆腐もすごい柔らかくてさ、茶わ蒸しみたいにお醤油かけて食べるのと、
あとさ、アメリカで売ってる豆腐ってあれ、すぐ固くて、あれ切ってさ。
そう?うん。お味噌汁に入れて。
うん。
それでも最後にさ、できた後に入れるからさ、ゆでるって言っても温めるだけだと思う。
お豆腐はどこかにお料理を上手に覚えたんだろうと。
いや、クイシンボは。
うん。
食べが ихを照らしてくれる
agani estar
主 ce
ご飯
ивать
ピッチもすごいおいしい
うんうん
いえ、今日朝食べたしやる
いえ、今日朝食べてくれ
よく詰めてある
ああ
本当
き Former
era
てい
てい ええ 何て言うんだっけ えっとー 名前忘れちゃった
nm 引き引きも入ってるぞ
エファ小さい白いのにあって生きてるん アーバヌイルとかいん
あの ああん ああん ええええええ
ねえ めっ
んー なんかこういうパンとパン美味しいからよかったら持ってきてね 全然あっとに ああんに大丈夫大丈夫
ん
この後どっか座れたらねえっと 昨日
パパのパパいっぱいカメラで写真撮ってるじゃん でもそれ昔の写真さえっと
なんかいろいろ オーガナイズしてて
ん めんめんも見たいかなと思う 持ってきたよ
ん 持ってきたよいっ
Thank you.
I don't have a lot of food.
In France, I don't have a lot of food.
How do you eat a lot of food?
I don't have a lot of food.
Mmm.
It's good.
It's good. It's cold.
But, in Japan, I'd like to have a dinner.
If it's good, I'll have a second to go back to the kitchen.
It's good.
It's bad.
There's a lot of food in America.
There's a lot of food in there.
I was a little bit of food in there.
金のトランペットをやってる人は見えるじゃん、あれ。
うん。
それじゃなくて。
金の人たちがあるから。
ああ。
そうね、なんか、
あれはもう、時間でなんか、みんな、みんな座って、お祈りとか言って、みんなこうやってたんこうになって、あの、やる、やって、それで、
ね、はい、そう。
何してる、ミスラムとか言うの?
うん。
それって、あの、何人が多いと思う?
どういう人がそういう人なんだ?
え、わかんない。
だけど、あの、みんなとこはもう、日本人と同じでね、顔が、それで、あの、日本語もペラペラなのよ。
え、インドネシア?
そういう人、あの、ミスラムっていうスーパーがあってね、
そういう人と、すごい可愛い男の子でね。
うん。
そういう人とね、何故か話すようになっちゃって。
そしたら、あの、それで、ある時、あの、今日は彼らいないんですかって、私、それ聞いちゃったんだ。
そしたら、誰かが呼んでたんだ。
よく行ったんだけど、ただ聞いただけだったんだけど、呼んで、降りてきて、それで、そしたら、今、お祈りしてたんですよっていう、
ああ、うん。
そういう人と、えぇ、って、お祈りって、私も、お祈りの時間があるんだよって言ったのね。
それで、あの、クリスチャンなのって言ったら、うん、あの、ね、ブルークラブなんだって言ったの。
へぇ。
だけど、もう、見たとこ、本当に日本人に、それが、少し、ちょっと黒いかな。
まあ、ちょっとだけ黒いんだけど、でも、すごく可愛いんだけど、でも、なんか、
そこで、私も色々失敗したから、日々から、松倉に行かない。
えぇ。
だって、だって、あの、あの、あの、メールアドレスするみたいなの、あの、お電話で、かけられる。
うん。
電話かけて、なんか、ちょっとかけるじゃない。携帯に。そういう、そういう番号だって言ってくれたからね。だから、なんか、色々書いちゃったね。
あ、そっか。
そういう人は、それ、彼1人の方がなかったの。
あははは。
そういう、そんな人が見ちゃってね。
うん。
それなんか、あの、あの、書くのはダメだったんだよって言うわけだったんだけど、そんなことしたって、そうマルーンを流したら、電話なんか、普段できないですね。
そういう人がやっているのが、そういう人だからね。あの、あの、実はいなかったかな。
実はね、あの、実はね、実はなかったよね。なんか、みんなで日誌に行った時、いっぱいなかったよね。
彼がいたのかな。誰か、アムちゃんが、誰かいた。
彼が、アムちゃんが、誰かいた。アムちゃんが、何かいた。アムちゃんが、何かにアムちゃんがいたの。すごい綺麗だから、みんなが、アムに行った。
そう、彼と、誰かと私と、
私の知ってる人が、なんていう名前だっけ、変な名前なんだよ、それを。だからこの人って何人だろうと思ってね。
あんまり日本人じゃないって思わないわけ、普通話してれば、ちょっと黒いして、ちょっと見ようと。
あれ? 目とかも本当に日本人のタイプ。 インドネシアってモーズドームいっぱいいるんだよね。
インドネシアってお前ね。インドネシアに俺も行ったからね。
インドネシアでいっぱい、なんだっけ、モーズドーム入って、頭のカバーみたいなのあるじゃん。
マービーの? そうそうそうそう。それいっぱい。
それであの、なんか、別にね、そんなラブレターを書いたもんないんだけど、
でも、なんか、書いちゃった。今度、いつ行くから、ありますね。
だって、お店だから、それ。スーパーマーケットだから。
うんうん。 いつ来るかわかんないって言ってた。
初め、自動車のね、あの、駐車場のテレビみたいなのやってたの。
その人、2人だったかな。 西野。
西野。 普通に、あの、あそこ。
ナショナルとか、自分でいられるんだけど、
メディアとかね、そういうところはちょっとうるさいことがあるんだけど、
いくら買わないと、タダじゃないとか、いろいろなんで、全然認識もちょっとあるんだけど、
結構うるさくて、なんか、自分で、自動車を持ってきてくれたり、いろいろするのよ。
ああ。
そういうのやってる人、お母さんとか、何人とか一緒にやってて、
それが、あの、あの、あの、あの、あの、あの、あの、お母さんとかね、もう、大騒ぎだったんだよ、って言うからね。
えぇーって。
もう、どうするっていうか。
こんなおばあちゃんだからいいじゃない人だから、おばあちゃんなんだから本当に、祈りそれ。
若い人だったら期待やと思うんですけど、それで来かいから行かなくなって、だから今のことを「ここ、おっぱいルシアに行こう」とか言ってたんだよね。
「あ、そうか」。それで「メイメイ、ニシア好きでしょ?」って言ってくれて。好きだったけど。
でも、いろんな面白いものを売っててね。日本のものも売ってるし、いろんな世界でのものを売ってて。
なんかナショナラゾンみたいだよね。
もっとなんか広くていろいろ。
ベーコンとかいっぱい
いろんなお
大きいベーコンが乗ってたって言ったっけ
誰からそういう話
ベーコンが乗ってるからって
美味しそうだと思って
こんな大きなベーコンなの
ただにしてた
日本ってさベーコンじゃなくてハムなんだよ
そうよね
ハムは
美味しい
だから
電話かけても
普段は誰も出ないわけ
みんなそこで働いてる人が
3人か4人同じ電話を
向かってるらしいのよ
よく知らないんだけど
いくらかけても誰も出たことがないってね
それで帰ったわけ
それで大失敗した
行ってくれればいいのにって感じ
なんか返事してくれるわね
いつもわかったんだけど
それで
なんでだろう
それでなんかあの
それで今度ずっとほっといてね
もう行かないでな
なんかある時あの
なんかちょっともう仕事終わったって
いつもあの
夜は夜は夜は遅くまで働いてたのね
ああ
だからもうお家帰るのってちょっと帰ってある時から
今雨来ててね
そのカバスとそれと両方もお隣をって
帰ってきられちゃった
ああ
もういつもなんで
私も本当にこんなおばあちゃんと
散らしてる
いやいやいや
いや
まだまだ
みんな笑ってるんじゃない
ああ
いやいや
そうなっちゃったんだ
でもなんかその
ポテト行った時
あの誰がいたんだ
誰か
そのなんて
お客さんじゃないか
誰か連れてったのよ
他の知ってる
他の女性の方を
誰だったっけ
あれを
連れてたんだけど
なんか4人ぐらいで行ってね
私と言って
へえ
それでその時ね
そのお客さんに来たら
他の自動車の
整理してる人
他にみんな連れて挨拶になってきたの
ああ
そういう
あ
でもそうか
そのカップ前だって
ああ
そうか
だから
英語の方が来てくれたら
思うな
って言って
へえ
はい
私は
いろんなところで
持てるんです
笑
そうだよ
また帰る?
今もずっと一人じゃない?
日本のおじいちゃんと一緒に歩くなんてことはあんまりないからね
うんうん
でも別にトシコさんと転化したり
そういうのは全然ないよね
トシコさんとも話をする
もう一回行けばいいのに
行ってみたら
今朝も何か行ってたよ
うん
それでなんかあの
しばらくずっと
前一番最初にもあったの
その時もなんかとても親切だったんだけど
普通にね
普通に荷物持ってくれたり
ちょっとスロックスイングが知られて
それであの
ずっと会わないで
そしたらなんか
お気に入りのことにしてもね
ずっと焦りてたんだけどね
おとととに急に思い出したんですよって言ったのね
それで
おととに思い出してくれたみたいなんだけど
そうは言わないから
うんうん
だから
おととぐらいもたほうがちょっと思い出したんだって言ったから
そう?あの
不思議ねって言っちゃったの
それでね
その時はそんなこと考えてもなくて
なんか、それは大失敗だと思う。 車みたいだと思われてると、みんなに思う恥ずかしい。
いやいや、おかしいだけだって。
別にね、そんなすごくね、 すごいやー、会いたいなとか、そんなこと書いてないんだけどね。
いつ作るから、どこかって言いますかとかね。 そういうようなことを書いてあげたけど。
あと、電話で見るとさ、一人ずつのさ、 書くのとさ、いろいろいっぱい入ってる人の文、 同じように見えるじゃん。
ああ、そうね。
いや、何回もやったことあるよ、それ。
うん。
でも、インターネットっていうか、あの、 パソコンとか、文字ってないのかもしれない、こんな感じなの。
電話でね、電話でね、そうやって、 書くと書いて。
うん。
そうだよね。
ああ、おいしぱ。
ああ。
でも、リキュリキさんなんて、とっても、あの、 何だろう、国物だから、いろんな面で、だから、あの、 女の子にもってるんです。
そうが、こうです。
いや。
はい。この前、もう…
可愛い子の人がいるかもしれない。
2年前、アラスカ行った時さ、色々。
アラスカラって言ってた。
昔、メンメン、飛行機ってアラスカ行っても止まってたんでしょ?
うん。
空港だけ?それとも、一泊ぐらい止まってた?
見たことない、アラスカは。
でも、アラスカはちょっと降りたりしてみたけどね。
綺麗だけど、やっぱり一年中いたら楽そうよね。
うん。でも、夏が一番いいらしい。
全然熱くならないから。
ちょっとしらない。
はい。
キャンパーショー。
私は、今度はリクちゃんをメンメンに来ていないから、あの…。
前に来た時は、パパとか一人だったよね。
うん。
だから、誰も来たなんて思ってないけど。
一人でできたら、ちょっと…。
あなたの、彼女のボーイフレンドができたんじゃない?って言われる。
いやいや、何か来たじゃん。一人で。
そうだった気はする。
うん。いや、今回じゃないけど。
だけど、みんなが見てるわ。いわゆるボーイフレンドっていうのは、みんなシンサーだったね。
あ、そっか。
そのシンサー、今、セサスっていうところに映っちゃった中国人のシンサー。
あ、もう。
すごくいい方でね、よく来てたのね。
その頃、運転してたから、帰りを伝えたりして。
へぇ。
えぇ。
え、まだ、まだ帰っちゃったんですか?
うん。
今、もう、ずっと、セサスっていうところにいるの。
あー。
だけど、なんか、そこ行く道は分からなくて、
うん。
だから、あの、一回、うちに来たから、
今日帰り、道を覚えるかもしれない。
「行ってあげる」って言ったんで、
ちょっと、その頃に行ったんで、
で、そしたら、あの、残念ながら、めちゃくちゃ混んじゃった。
あ、あ。
それで、最後になって、ほとんど、こう、動かないくらい混んじゃって、
そしたら、突然ね、ここからもう、歩いた方が早いから、
もう、行くね、バイバイとか、
あ、バイって降りちゃった。
うん。
あの時も「一応、おうちのために行かれたのよ」って言ったんだけど、そんなこともあんまり聞いとかないだって。
そういう時に、最初六本木に行ったのね。
その時は、その時は、日本人の人がいるので、そこに入ってらっしゃる。
一人はフェリピン人で、一人はインド人で。
日本人はみんな違うところに聞かれてね。
それって何年か決まってるの?
その時にやるんじゃない?
何年経つと終わるみたいな仕事みたいな。
もう、大変だろうと思うけど、あれじゃない?
そういう時は、一人も、別南から来た方は、青森に行かされてね。
手元はいるんだって、そこに。
その時は、その時はあんまり話してなくてね。
手元はいるんだって、そこに行くと。
そこに行くと。
どうしても、どうしても、そこに行くと。
"いつ Dockerが違う numbers potentially?"
"カラow:XXXX"
マクロ;N: Um.
" Всёозаищー"
"Russell" 一回 Byred??
"Sh Advance"
"Sexasperia"
"この前じゃなくてその前の前年目アメリカ来た時さ覚えてる あれニュージェルシーのホテルみたいなのが泊まって"
"Sexasperia" 今まだアメリカでもあのー"
"Itspo" 確かに違う業界にしたけど、あのニューヨークではね、国7人とMちゃんはまだ
エミが知ってるとこ行っていて、どこだったら全然わからないですね。
今エミちゃんはどこにいるの?
ボッソンです。まだ?
一度、あなたはどこだったか、室から見つぶり、その方に行っていて、そっちの方に行ってもいいと思って。
ちょっと病気になってしまった。
コンビスじゃない、違うので変なものが流行った。
割と最近だよ。去年ぐらい?
去年?
それにエミスすごく元気でね。
全然病気もしないし、疲れたりもしないのね。
だけど、その病気になっちゃって。
同じお仕事もらえなくなって。
だけど、まだ落ちたんだよ。
去年何が流行ったかな。
今もレタスに入ったバクテリアが流行ったけど。
夏だから、バクテリア病気になりやすい。
アメリカの中だったよ。
日本も大丈夫だけど、他のアジアの国だと、
あんまり流行ったら行けないっていう。
うん、南米も同じ。
そう?
え、なんだろう。大丈夫かな?
え、もう大丈夫?でも、今。
え、みちちゃん。
今、大丈夫?
でも、すごく元気だったんだけど、そうでもなくなったらしい。
あ、そっか。
でも、小さじきは大変だったのよ。
もう、ママがいなかったら泣いちゃうのね。
あ、そう。
ハワイに一度一緒に来たんだけど、何名が入っても全然ダメでね。
え?
ママが、くにくにぽんがちょっと、ちょっとなんか買いに出ちゃって。
うん。
そしたら、みちちゃんのドアのところで、ちょっと、そのまいといて、それに、そうと抱っこして、それで、なんか、絵本か、なんか見て。
えぇ。
日本語もそんなに、よくとは分からなくてね。
え、両方でも、ちょっと、その絵本の話をしたら、少し後で、少しは機嫌を直した。
えぇ。
あ、そうか。
でも、りきみたいに、お料理が上手だったら、もしもし、もし、もしだよ。もし、結婚したらね。
もう、奥様が困っちゃうよね。だって、お主人の方がお料理がすごい上手だったら、いやいやいや。
でも、何作ったってダメじゃない?だから。
いやぁ。
パパパもお料理好きだけど。
そうね。
うん。
パパもお料理好きだったら、そういうのも。
この時ってね、電話が駆ってきたんだけど、どうすればいいの?
えー
押すと、こんな風な出てくるじゃない?
電話してる時、やでみていい?
緑のボタンがあるはずなんだけど
これ、こうやって出てくるからね
これ
なんかね、ここにいろんなことが書いてあるわけ
「You should keep your time to sleep」とか書いてある
そんな、いつもその後、電話してたりすると
それで出会ってないんだけどね
あの、iPhoneでやってるんだけど
でもちょうど、it's time for you to sleepだけど
「You should keep your time to sleep」
「いや、ずっと座ってるとね、You should keep your time to sleep」とか
「出てくるよ」
「うん」
え、え、え、めめに見せたい写真があるんだけど
いっぱい、昨日見てた
古いやつね、あれ2013年とか
そこに行ったとこに座るとこがある
で、テーブルもあってね
ラヒムが乾かしても大丈夫とか
これをじゃあどこに下げてたか
あ、下げてあげる、そこに
でもね、せっかく日が日本にいる日が
日にちを伸ばしたりしてくれてるんだから
「どうしたら楽しかった?」
「いやいや、全然楽しいや」だって
「全然大丈夫?」
お疲れ様でした
持ってくる
これでいいと思う
ありがとうございました。
ママがスーツケースに入らなくて置いてたお土産がいっぱいあるからね
それ持っていかなきゃいけない
あといろいろなんかやっぱりこれ買ってとか頼まれたし
なんかどっか座って写真見る?
あそこ?
え、そこ?
うん。
え、そう?
え、じゃあ、行こう行こう。
ね。
うん。
見て、これ。なにこれ。
わかんない。
スイカのボールみたいなやつ。
なんかね。
ん?
たった5個でこんな高めで、
どんな高めで。
これ。
モナカなの?
モナカって知ってる?
あの、こういう。
うん。
アンコ。
これ、アメが入ってる。
そうみたいね。
うん。
もうしろ。
ご視聴ありがとうございました
e poi sarà da
aicoico
Qui si
Faccio
Qui ostacano
Bl likes
No
Nermin
Il
*識 studenti/bronomi/ライ AKDASI IN NO NAT changed 기분
*識 studenti/bronomi/ライ AKDASI IN NO NAT
本当にそんなことに近いのか
今日その本当思ってたんだけど
今度はそうしたといかないだろう
もちろんこの本とかの年はありました
うんうん
でもね、そのどんなけの今度見るのはあの
おじいちゃんじゃなくて私がそうなんだけど
もう半分のものは私のあの
おじいちゃんはあの
グレートフランファーダーのね
わー
照らしたものとかを少し飾るらしくて
それはちょっと見たいのね
うんうん
それで今の半分は今の完全に新しいなんか
えっと
じゃあ少し悪い
へー
えぇー
エロウィン行こう
ん?
パスコ
ん
いや
これ
こんな感じ
入ってる
はい
あれ?
これ、えっと、メメに送るよ
こんな古いの見てない?
これ、私と見た
かわいい
これ、なんか照明書の写真でね
うん
写真撮っていい?
今度また
すごい
今度また、グリーカードのインタビューの時に写真がいるの?
だけど、こんなのしかなくて、どれがいいか
もう一つ割といいのがあったら、どっかに行ったのよ
かわいい
ね、どれがいいか
あんまりみんな良くない
これ、もうまだ髪型変わってないね
うん